le des comptines ça va ou quoi tout le
monde attend le déconfinement
normalement le déconfinement devrait
commencer le 11 mai alors pourquoi le 11
mai on sait pas on dirait un chiffre
choisi au hasard en zone mais on pense
tous que le 11 mai ça va être comme ça
en fait non il ya un plan de
déconfinement qui se met en place peu à
peu je sais pas s'il ya un petit peu lui
les prévisions mais apparemment ça n'a
pas aidé c'est ouf que ça finalement je
retourne chez moi
par contre l'activité professionnelle
devrait reprendre donc les magasins de
vêtements ou les coiffeurs devrait
réouvrir donc on pourra enfin se faire
beau pour aller à ba2 le par alors ils
ont prévenu après les confinements rien
ne sera comme dans le monde d'avant le
monde d'avancé on dire un titre à la
tolkien le monde avant un monde qui a
existé jadis bas en février en fait donc
bah c'est pas très dur
la bise et la poignée de main c'est
terminé ça c'est fini à mon avis
peut-être pour toujours
on va tous porter des masques plaisir
bonjour de loin on est en train de
copier l'asie en scred d'un côté les
réunions publiques seront interdites
mais de l'autre les écoles seront
ouvertes n'est pas possible comment tu
veux expliquer les gestes barrière à
quelqu'un qui lèche la barrière
ça va surtout être floue pour les
enfants ça va être une rentrée très
spécial dit souvent mon chéri demain
c'est la rentrée des classes du
déconfinement et comme à toutes les
rentrées j'étais préparé une petite
tenue pour que tu sois le plus bourru
l'école des copeaux vont être jaloux et
pour la récré talent a par contre vu
prétendants la personne tu le gardes
pour tous je te rappelle on est une
famille devra ses rôles où l'on peut
comprendre les parents qui ont besoin
d'être enfant à l'école pour aller
bosser et des enfants qui en ont marre
d'avoir comme prof leurs parents qui
sont des brêles le déconfinement on
attend tous que ça et franchement quand
on regarde ce qui se passe
le reste du monde on en est très très
loin en inde la police donnent des coups
de bâton ou des gifles à ce qu'ils
respectent pas le confinement bête
d'ambiance et les oblige à faire des
squats ou des pompes et touristes qui
respectent pas confinement de l'écrire
500 fois le mot pardon on est en ce2 ou
c'est quoi ce délire
en argentine on les fait marcher comme
des canards en afrique du sud la police
tire carrément sur les gens au brésil il
ya borsalino ball sonar oh [ __ ] chez
apple
bref le président qui fait des bains de
foule sans aucune pression le président
chinois lui est pas très claire sur les
chiffres de mortalité de son pays alors
on avait dit mercredi 3000 morts mais en
fait je me suis trompé c'est plutôt 4500
à non pardon en fait c'est plutôt 2
millions j'ai complètement étourdi moi
c'est dans ce cas la base de mon cher
les manger ma copie heureusement le
président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko nous donne un vrai conseil
pour vaincre le coronavirus je dis qu'il
faut non seulement se laver les mains
avec de la vodka mais il faut aussi en
boire 40 à 50 grammes par jour bref si
le bordel et c'est le bordel partout
donc arrêtez de faire croire que vous
savez pas ce que vous n'avez pas trop
l'air de savoir les hôpitaux français
sont toujours prêts on n'est pas prêt
pas du tout c'est plutôt le moment de
faire des bonnes affaires
en bourse la bourse de paris vient tout
simplement de vivre la pire journée de
son histoire qu'on va pas fermer toutes
les écoles de france les écoles seront
fermées cas pas de risque de pénurie on
n'a plus de stocks disponibles ils sont
en rupture fabricant je pense vraiment
pas qu'ils aient d'épidémie en franchise
cette épidémie est la plus grave crise
sanitaire qui est connue la france
depuis un siècle
porter un masque en population générale
ça ne sert à rien nous encouragerons
effectivement le grand public s'il le
souhaite apporter des mac donc voulu
nous dire on a plus de masques nous dit
il faut pas apporter forcément c'est
plus simple et la médaille d'or revient
en champion du monde en titre
nos bagages les etats unis qui
enregistre à ce jour 25 mille 700 décès
dus aux coronavirus sarah comptait pas
mal hein trump au début de l'épidémie
tout comme boris johnson
si le mec va fouiller chaque mot par
contre c'est mon boulot ce quoi boris
vian fait chaque président j'arrive pas
à le dire en fait c'est là que l'on voit
que j'ai clairement pas fait sciences po
tout comme boris johnson qui au début je
faisais de viarmes alain goualch au
crédit des bons résultats
quinze jours plus tard en tout cas chez
nous en france tout a changé tous les
soirs à la télé c'est plus hanouna
convoi mais jérôme salomon talus les
fans de 11
il est en train de buzz et jérôme
salomon mais d'une puissance didier
raoult on peut dire qu'il est presque
devenu youtuber certainement de vidéos
qui en plus cartonne game les gens jeu
didier raoult pour une nouvelle vidéo
qu'on a traitées ici allez je suis mes
carnets infections plus de 3000
personnes qu'on a une mortalité qui est
inférieur à 0 5 % ce qui est le résultat
le plus spectaculaire actuellement au
monde et maintenant la population
française a vraiment pris les devants
tout est fait maison des masques fait
maison avec des filtres à café plein de
gens se sont mis à faire leur propre
pain leur propre coiffure bientôt ça va
être quoi
et voilà désolé je peux le changer dans
sa salle de faire un petit peu mal bon
espérons le sens que plus le temps passe
plus on découvre que le virus dangereux
on dirait que chaque jour il ya un
nouveau symptôme purgera que j'ai perdu
le goût l'odorat
non je crois que tous aient pas cuisiner
c'est vraiment des graisses ton truc
gérant perd du coup c'est sûr non c'est
dégueulasse ou alors ces deux le costaud
j'ai perdu le goût est ouest pas ou quoi
alors il paraît que tous les vendredis à
18 heures il ya des apéros balcon pour
trinquer que ses voisins j'avoue que
juste parler à quelqu'un d'extérieur
ça veut du bien moi j'ai croisé mon
voisin à quelques jour là j'avais envie
de la discussion ne s'arrête pas quoi et
voilà je sors les poubelles quoi comme
comme tous les jours et si on se demande
à quoi me dis moi ce que je viens de
parler à quelqu'un des pas ce que vous
voulez je m'en fous mais auprès des
petits pois découle bien cuit ou alors
oui quand est confiné en couple au moins
tu as quelqu'un à qui parler
sûr mais c'est pas pareil alors tu aimes
la personne c'est pas le problème mais
comment dire en fait quand j'ai dit que
je voulais vivre avec toi tu sais je
pensais pas autant
ça fait quand même beaucoup de jours
d'affilée sympa la presse c'est une
petite pose aussi pour relancer le bien
soit alors il ya un nouveau terme pour
dire rompré quelqu'un par facetime en
confinement le zoom ping l'expression
est inventée par le journal the guardian
qui a croisé les mots zone et dumping
donc les gens en couple en confinement
attention ne pas vous faire zoom bingo
c'est qu'on a un confinement et que ça
se fait pas mais j'ai bien réfléchi et
je pense que je ne mérite pas voilà
c'est fini entre nous je suis désolé je
peux finir alors c'est pas parce qu'on
vit une pandémie mondiale que les
connards nos barbus il ya des escrocs
qui se promène dans la rue
habillant faux flics et qui met d amende
de 135 balle à des gens naïfs qui n'ont
pas leurs justificatifs sur eux quoi des
fils de cheikh par le même genre et
aussi des personnes qui débarquent chez
les gens en combinaison sous prétexte
qu'ils vont désinfecter la maison est en
fait c'est des cambrioleurs donc faites
bien attention donc là vous désinfecter
la web et là on désinfecte tous les
objets qui pourraient être un peu
contagieux d'ailleurs si vous avez des
cartes bancaires n'hésitez pas à me les
donner avec le code ainsi possible est
ce que pour éviter à apporter la télé
parce que quatre cas c est quand même
assez lourds belles années 2020 elle est
vraiment pourra venez on dit que le 11
mai on passe directement en 2021
comme ça on repart sur de bonnes bases
on fait que ça ouais génial quoi qu'il
en soit il faut qu'on reste encore tous
chez nous quelques temps même si c'est
de plus en plus difficile en pas se
mentir
et comme dirait ce vieux proverbe les
bateaux sont à l'abri au port mais ils
ne sont pas faits pour ça
ceux qui sont pas encore abonnés à la
chaîne youtube fait que tout simplement
en cliquant ici et votre souris où elle
vos doigts ou avec n'importe quel membre
de votre corps ça me regarde pas et on
se revoit très bientôt pour une nouvelle
vidéo sur la suite des événements c'est
à dire ciao
[Musique]